it's always one heartbreak after another there are people who just love the
drama of relationship but I don't think anyone specifically pines for heartbreak
I mean I always give my best I try to be more than fair as a girlfriend but
sometimes I get nit thinking that somehow it's all my fault I just can't
wrap my head around how that could be possible it's times like this where I
try to think back to the start of my love life starting with my first love and
first loss maybe try to compare and see where I went wrong this time it started
back in early college I was studying to become a fashion designer if you can
believe that I wasn't as well deliciously brazen in my outfit choices as I am now
a quiet much too overlooked girl who never got invited to parties their loss
though I imagine I had more fun sewing crafting and anything else a grandma
would do with spare time an old soul people would call me I was content in
my own quiet that was until I met my first love I don't know what he saw in
me but he was the one to make the first move even before I had the mind
to dress to attract the male gaze here I was more of an all-miss chic ghost
whatever the reason here was a man who takes charge where he needs to he was
a dirty rabid-looking man who stank of booze and ooze failure and degeneracy in
retrospect in our first meeting it was a bit more pushy than I'm used to
nowadays it's best to understand that the pillar of a strong relationship is
setting up boundaries and it's best to do it as soon as possible putting your
foot down telling your partner what's what it's a risk you have to take it was
because of that I remember that I always keep my fabric scissors with me when
you interact with your partner honestly if the love is true they can feel your
intent that's when the honest purest part of them comes out my favorite stage
in all of my relationships it was like he was a completely different person
from his introduction he showed me his true self a part men are taught to hide
away the soft sweet vulnerable man inside I mean how could I not fall for him I
don't think I have a particular type per se but a man who expresses his
emotions in such a delicious way that's something I couldn't resist I just had
to have him I had brought him to an old shed my family owns the best I could do
at the time but together our love can make it all you see good relationships
are built on compromise and I and compromise I did I gave that man
everything everything you could ever want I bathed him fed him cared for him
gave myself to him the time we spent I gave him all I had to give that's what
relationships are I give and take you give your all to someone and you expect
them to do the same for you and you know what he does just runs away out of the
blue no talking no indication anything is wrong just leaves I couldn't
understand I was high off of my affection for him and I thought he was
the same but I had to hold in my sadness I for one am better than leaving
without a word relationships no matter what should be ended properly after all
sometimes relationships don't work out for reasons you don't understand but
where there was true love there can be a lot of fun to be had right before
cutting ties
after that it was fling after fling a new love here and there all ending the
same way I hate having to be the nice one in the relationship it can't be my
fault I guess men will take any chance to abuse your kindness now the breakup
songs on the radio start to make sense and the sweetest sugars are now as
bitter as vinegar it's times like this when I think I'm about to give up on
love entirely but as they say time heals all wounds after that it feels like
the very first time
wake up Senpai Senpai wake up oh you're still a bit dizzy that's okay I hit
you on the head pretty hard up an atom though it's a shame but we don't have
a lot of time together welcome Senpai I finally have you I've been waiting for
this moment for so long and I hear you've been waiting for me too what do
you think of icy and Azra's debut don't you just want to cuddle icy and Azra
makes you feel so protected right fortunately for you I will also keep
for now just be good I heard you wanted to get to know me better so I brought my
special love diary with all the information about me that you need to
know so we can be together forever and I'll have all the time in the world to
get to know you too so let's get started my name is mercy modeste mercy being the
last thing people say before they're killed and modeste meaning dressmaker
in French my birthday is March 15th so in Japanese that's 315 so 315 is
Saikou so and site Saikou means the best age oh oh sorry don't worry about
that that's not my blood oh where was I I am an ex student and my height is 160
centimeters tall meaning I'm about five three in freedom unit mm-hmm okay you got
that Senpai mm-hmm okay here are my likes Senpai I love you Senpai I love
you so much I also really love your snacks children's cartoon uh color
coordination so if we ever wear matching outfits together art books they make me
so happy because I just love to look at pretty arts and pretty things and I love
phrase especially from you Senpai I love phrase it makes me so happy if you say
you love me and if you like anything that I do it makes me really really happy
as my dislikes I dislike eggs all kinds of eggs I'm allergic I dislike porridge
it makes me no I just just I dislike it it makes it reminds me of when I'm sick
um beer I don't like beer but I do like beer snacks so I like the saltiness of
beer snacks but not beer I dislike coffee the bad fridge coffee flavor things are
okay though I dislike carbonation as well because well my you my you villa is
kind of enlargent enlarged so it makes my my my throat kind of irritated so I
don't like carbonation I don't like math and numbers because it's harder to
memorize like memorizing your phone number Senpai is so hard and where you
live like the the number in front of where you live that's so hard it's
really hard to memorize all that so please memorize all this you'll make me
very very very happy if you do all right oh here we go here's my favorite
anime it's okay if you don't know these but if you do know these you are based
and super lit etc but if you don't know these that's okay I'm kind of pretentious
I'm kind of pretentious and I kind of have like pretentious likes so some
notable ones here for animes I like our cardcaptor Sakura hunter hunter dungeon
meshi death knelt cowboy beat bop I think you understand my tastes from all
those as for games I like as well I love story based games and almost all games
I play are our PG pointing clicks visual novels that focus on storytelling
um especially mystery and detective games as you can see though I really
need to expand my gaming repertoire so please help me Senpai some games that I
really like are a yokai watch eastward SMT-4 I like fourth one
vahala in the nonaries the nonary games so those are really fun to play as for
movies I like I believe these are the best of the best so it's the greasy
strangler ego I go swatches such a beautiful day Sherlock junior imitation
of life rope peeping Tom I can't wait to share them with you Senpai I hope we
can do like watch alongs of my favorites as for music I kind of don't listen to
music I kind of don't listen to music so all I really listen to are like
classical music game OSTs any any songs pop music and like songs my friends made
and recommend to me but yeah I like working in silence so I hope that's
okay all right all right here are the credits thank you everyone on these
pages for helping me meet you senpais all the credits will also be on the
Villalor website so I'd like to give special thanks to design squishy ghoul
and the rig being Nari thank you so much everyone on this page for allowing me to
meet Senpai I am so so so so so thankful all right skill time okay whoa here are
my skills I am super perceptive so if something's wrong I will know right away
I'm like a little secret detective so if something's wrong or if I find little
patterns in the way you talk that's different I will notice I can speak
and I can I know only like really baby Japanese so um
I have a decent acting and decent singing skills as well a variety of interesting
laughs and noises and I'm a super ganky girl my hobbies are snooping photography
research media study being a total weeb fashion design and well what's this
down here oh oh who put that there these are my weaknesses it's it's fine for
for my senpais to know because weaknesses are have to be shared with each
other so my weakness is motion sickness I'm sorry that's that is why most of my
games are like that I have very bad motion sickness that I'm trying to get
over impatient I mean sorry that's the third thing in the way overthinking I
tend to overthink a lot and if things are too simple I might in puzzles I might
overthink them and just go like no it can't be that simple and of course in
patience I'm I'm a little impatient with a lot of things so please forgive me
after all we all have weaknesses all right okay okay here are my goals senpai
I have so many goals I have so many goals if I have more and I went through them
take a long time to get through so here are just a handful that I picked so my
goals are to pursue voice acting and appear in an anime or video game move
to a place with better internet get a sound isolation booth get over my
motion sickness to play first-person games host a concert and perform 3d
lives or events or even 3d skits to bring to life my original songs that I
wrote I have a few written in my notes to have a product based off of me to
bring home a play button for my mother who's always wanted to see one to reach
over a million senpai's and make them smile and to make memories with you my
darling senpai and of course the best one of all to reach my perfect fairytale
happily ever after understand and I won't let anyone get in that way
all right here are my tags senpai I have no idea I'm not very creative I'm not
very punny with my tags as well so in 2.0 I'm going to ask my senpai's for a
bit of help with my tags so for example my general tag I need something for that
I need clips for my live I've decided on mm online I'm not sure if that's really
clever though so if you guys could could help me if my senpai's could help me
art is mode elucid if that's not really cool you guys can can also help me pick
a new one my alt to art tag is mode modi's lead lewd my meme tags I know this
is gonna be cringe but it's modi's modi's nuts my oh she mark is a pair of
scissors broken the heart but I don't want my heart broken so you guys will
fix that up right and the fan name for these little guys are called snippets
originally they were supposed to be called heartbreakers but I really don't
want my heart broken so now they're little snippets aren't they really cute
aren't they little aren't they super super adorable guy I think they're super
cute oh they're so sweet all right let's talk about my favorite thing my
gen mates aren't they super cute these are drawn in the style of set cheese like
blue archive blue archive work so they're super super funny and cute so my
first impressions of my gen mates is that in me is surprisingly hick but in a
cute way baby girl can be quite ruthless super talented at everything she does
has no weaknesses and she's super funny she's a she's a super memer I see when
I first saw her I thought she would be super messy get key and guess what I was
right she's a baby polar bear would protect but she'll probably bite me
actually the cutest as I said she doesn't have the best food takes I think
that she likes she has really good food and she's a really passionate and
amazing DJ you guys saw that set right so good and then there's mommy
mommy sometimes I'm scared of her not gonna lie sometimes I'm scared of her
but I feel very loved she's easygoing as much as she doesn't say she's like she
says that she's not professional I believe she's super professional as well
and she's very clumsy but in a like a super cute way she be she be is so brave
like everything is waters off the ducks back very independent cool independent
woman she's a hard worker maybe she works too hard she has such a wide range in
her voice as well so I think that's really cool that she's like able to reach
different voice tones that's that's really amazing
Azura right here is I thought she was a dancer when I first saw her because of
her colors or like a fortune teller she is mommy like that's it she's mommy that's
it her voice is very good I have never heard a voice so so dripping and like
plus
before she's super funny really good at games whoops my ass all the time in any sort of games
she's just a great gamer and uh a legatic
uh I love her I love them so much
all right let me show you off show me off to you guys now to my senpai's all right
okay look at my feetsies and my
calf my calf uh height socks striped socks with my knee high fishnet socks as well
you can't see that part sorry so here you go I have wonderful garters on me
with band-aids and wonder and and like scissors here I'm sorry about the band-aids I'm just
really clumsy guys I worked really hard to get here so I just I just wanted I just I fell over
a lot because I was so in love my scissors my beautiful bouncy bowl and of course my choker
let's have a closer look home
all right here's some of my expressions that I can do
I can look like this weird little freaking hamster
I can be really angry if you guys piss me off
suddenly there seems to be no more senpai's
you can I can cry you don't want to make me sad right senpai
I also have a dark face so if I'm very disappointed in you
I also have dead fish eyes oh wow that's so funny wow
blush in case I love you so much senpai I love you love you love you love you
and heart eyes which I always am in love with you senpai always always always
question mark oh sorry it's a little bit up a question mark
what did you mean by that what happened I don't get it
my shocked eyes senpai you love me right you love me right you love me right
I can smile a little bit
uh I didn't mean for that to happen oops and of course my famous yandere hands
I love you so much senpai
and you may ask what's under my eye patch why it's another eye
I wear this eye patch so I can see in the dark so one eye is always in the dark so I can always
see you no matter what senpai this might be a little disappointing huh but that's okay
I feel a little naked without my eye patch so that's gonna go away
all right let's continue on
here is my schedule senpai so tomorrow we're gonna do debut 2.0 so we can have more chats and I can
rant more about things with you also we're playing killer seven the day after
omori my first time asmr ever ever ever so I hope I'm well I won't disappoint you guys I'm
quite new to this uh a difficult game about climbing designing my gym mate's office a
harvester and death mark it's a pretty full week coming up but I'm I will be slowing down a little
bit afterward so please don't think that I'm gonna be overworking myself senpai all right so
now that that's sort of over I want you guys to like and subscribe
and leave a comment of course if you really truly love me but as always are times
gonna be cut short so
I want you to take a deep breath for me senpai
okay take a deep breath now really deeply now
say hi to Emmy won't you I'll see you soon
you
You